but there are probably two really simple  things that you can do non-medication  that are if you look at the data are  almost guaranteed to improve your sleep  which is some form of physical activity  most days or at least several days a  week and the second is deal with your  anxiety anxiety is the principal cause  of insomnia it's not the only cause  people who have a high fight or flight  activation of their nervous system they  also have high levels of stress  chemicals such as cortisol  and that seems to be very predictive of  their insomnia  and if you can start to manage your  anxiety for example meditation is a  fantastic practice  people  when they are suffering from insomnia if  you put them into a meditation a mindful  practice  you can actually drop the severity of  the insomnia um in a way that  medications yeah such even prescription  medications  can't come close to